race to make commercial space travel a
reality is really intensifying Virgin
Galactic reached a major milestone last
month for the first time a crewed
vehicle built for commercial passenger
service reach space the two astronauts
traveled listen to this 51 point 4 miles
above the Earth's surface now only on
CBS this morning we're announcing a
brand new partnership between Virgin
Galactic and Under Armour the
performance wear company will develop
space apparel and footwear for
astronauts engineers and fans Under
Armour very popular at this table will
also create an astronaut training
program that includes fitness and
nutrition plans to prepare future
passengers for space travel so joining
us now are Sir Richard Branson he's the
founders you know a virgin group which
includes Virgin Galactic a little Sir
Richard and Kevin Plank founder and CEO
of Under Armour we welcome you all to
the table good morning welcome
ok so set the scene for us Kevin and
Richard how did this bromance
partnership this is serious business get
started where when how sir Rhett reduce
and well Kevin was on Necker Island yeah
but we have occasional conferences on a
rather beautiful item the Virgin I it's
a lovely Island it is the lovely thing
about being on an island is you have
time to talk and we spend a lot of time
chatting together got to know each other
really well I'm sort of the older
entrepreneurs so I could give this young
man a bit of it fatherly advice we
became great friends and and just
decided to do some things together is
that how you remember it - Kevin said I
mean in my world you know Sir Richard
Branson was uh you know larger than life
and so there's nothing more disarming
than someone approaching you wearing
beach shorts Kevin what were you wearing
-
you out of it the most spectacular
athletes in the world
now what are gonna do in terms of
helping in terms of space space outfit
well the cool thing is that a build
space suit it's all the technology we've
had over 23 years of the company being
in business is something we get to apply
now to something as real as space and
watching this all come to life is
something I think it's a dream for so
many around the planet and it's such a
massive vision so all the technologies
that we're using it's basically this is
the kind of project that our team looks
at and says I can't believe we get to
build and do something for space so the
cool thing is that everything that we're
actually putting into the spacesuits and
technologies it's things that we've
already have are things that are
actually coming to market so this is so
in line with what and who we are as a
technical brand so our ability to be
that the the technical space we're
partner for Virgin Galactic is such a
cool opportunity when I first came
across Under Armour I felt like it was
already clothing from the future so so
he's on brand I think you know if you if
you if you're going to space it's going
to be you know you've got you got
married you know you have your children
and and the other thing you're going to
remember is that day you go to space and
and it's very important therefore that
you know when you look in the mirror
before you go to space you feel the part
you and that and the space the spacesuit
is very important and it needs to be it
needs to look good it needs to be
comfortable it needs to be safe and it's
just great working with Under Armour
they've got an incredible team of people
yeah speaking of looking the part you
are training for the part where are you
in that process of training to go to
space I'm actually really happy with
where we're at where I'm at I mean we do
a challenge every year with my kids than
we did two thousand kilometer bike bike
ride and hike earlier this year sorry at
the end of last year and and you know
I'm now so keeping you know keeping up
that fitness program so you know my aim
is you know to you know to have a body
of it a 30 year old by the car but when
I go to space and your age right now is
working how old do you feel I'm
approaching 69
and you know I honestly you know I'm
gonna just want a tennis woman I'm
feeling I'm feeling I'm feeling great
and I think you know I think if you if
you look after yourself and you know
find sort of an hour or two a day to
really look after yourself doesn't
matter what age you are you can you can
actually you know get your body back to
being very young so now soon do you guys
see people in space wearing an Under
Armor outfit this year this year really
yeah 19 yeah okay I mean I I will hope
to go up you know in the middle of this
year myself we've got another test
flight in a handful of weeks taking
place from a hobby then we'll have
another one a few weeks later than
another one and then we move everything
to New Mexico where we've got a
beautiful spaceport and then Richard
when you say you want to go up where
exactly are you going so the initial
flights that we're doing will be will
will put people into space they'll be
able to they'll go up into space that
three and a half thousand miles an hour
naught 2 naught 2 8 seconds and they'll
be able to unbuckle we've got the big
windows in the spaceship they'll float
around that will come an astronaut and
and then they'll come back in the state
in the same spaceship they've gone up in
and their land actually on the on the
wheels of the spaceship that we sent
them send them up into space and they'll
come back isn't you know one of the
first you know the first few hundred
people to become astronauts in the last
50 years and are you game for this Kevin
you going up so there's 600 people on
the waiting list right now you don't
want to we'll be right with it but no
it's not other question again the cool
thing is I think as you're thinking
about putting people in space the the
what goes into that process as well as
Richard talks about training for himself
but it's one of the other ways that
we're partnering is that with the
astronauts we're putting together
training programs for them often them to
go to our own performance center in
Portland Oregon
you know spend and prep and getting
ready to go into space and when they do
they can go up and they can feel better
and that's one thing that you know I
think it's pretty neat that we're gonna
be able to do from a technical
standpoint put people in space for
things that's
technology is available on the grounds
like this sweater that I'm wearing right
now actually built within telling it
which gives you the ability to modify
where you want to put different strands
so it's not like our cotton sweater or
sweater it's like it's built with rush
technology which allows you keep your
blood circulation keeps you moving which
is all incredibly and it looks good too
well Tom Brady and Steph Curry are two
of your athletes have you said listen
fellas I got an idea for you I got
another concur
well Steph actually had fun I think the
key to calling into question the actual
moon landing which was a total riveting
yeah but then it got it got going with
NASA so when they were downplaying the
Rockets he got a tour and so he like I
don't I don't think I don't think coach
girl would feel you don't want a
question buzzer Richard Branson CAF I do
thank you so much it breaks it breaks in
first week of February my word sighs
thank you thank you very much